let's go to our next question from Puma
not Huma Abedin presumably but a
different Cuba uma uma I'm not actually
sure how it's pronounced what food do
people commonly think is healthy but
really isn't okay
I've got one idea that's kind of a joke
but then lots of others carrot cake it
has the word carrot in it and people are
like hey it's really vegetables it's not
really vegetables it's sort of like
whether ketchup is considered vegetables
which was a thing I believe under Ronald
Reagan and the school lunch is it
something of a vegetable or king
possibly notable I don't know I'd call
it a vegetable
carrot cake now I do sort of take issue
with the concept of a healthy food or an
unhealthy food because a lot of it has
to do with sort of moderation and I read
some really good articles that reject
the idea of anything is fine to eat in
moderation that's not necessarily true
there are things that are just genuinely
not good for you but the concept of an
unhealthy food a healthy food a
superfood which we've talked about I
don't completely agree with that sort of
delineation but I think we can apply
some of this to these fruit juices where
they they say hey you've got a hundred
oranges in this 20 ounce juice that's an
insane amount of sugar and what you
really need to consider is people say
well I'm getting so much vitamin C
you're going to pee out a lot of that
vitamin C the body has a limit to how
much vitamin C it can absorb in a
24-hour period or whatever period but
you are taking in a lot of sugar and
even if it's unrefined sugar it's still
a ton of sugar I mean I guess whatever
you know as food being healthy or not
could be dependent on what else is in
your diet and you have any needs that
you have to get from other sources right
another thing that comes to my mind is
maybe like breakfast cereals because
they try to market those as a healthy
way to start your day yeah but then you
take a look at the ingredients and this
bunch of like food colorings and
preservatives and it's all like
processed grains I mean that can't be
too good for you corn especially -
there's a Calvin and Hobbes strip and I
grew up with Calvin and Hobbes I
recognize I've not
I couldn't rattle off every Calvin and
Hobbes strip but if you show me one I
recognize every single one I still
remember every
one there is one where Calvin gets these
chocolate frosted sugar bombs or
something like that and he gets obsessed
with them because you want to get some
little toy that you can get but if you
eat enough and get enough barcodes to
send in and at some point Hobbs suggests
that it might not be that healthy and it
counts as well as part of a balanced
breakfast and then Hobbs looks at the
box and it says yeah it's part of the
balanced breakfast pictured here which
includes you know or two gallons of
orange juice
a dozen fruits as well as scrambled eggs
like the amount of food that you would
need to balance it out might be two
weeks worth of breakfast food or
something like that yeah I think that
the breakfast cereal is a big racket
how about salads too because I mean you
think that is completely healthy but
yeah if you add like bacon bits and
cheeses and a a I'm very dressing that's
not healthy anymore I've seen this
abomination of a salad called the wedge
salad I don't know if you're familiar
with this you basically take a head of
iceberg lettuce and you cut I think it's
like a quarter of it you cut a quarter
so you've basically got this wedge right
so first of all iceberg lettuce it's of
almost no nutrition it's basically or
not take away literally why the arugula
whatever you put this wedge of salad on
the table on the plate and of course
that has zero calories and then you
cover it with blue cheese or gorgonzola
I don't remember which one ranch
dressing and bacon it's a salad folks
it's a nice healthy salad except 99
percent of the calories are from all the
other stuff and you're barely really
getting any vegetables there that's
gettin nefarious to because I'm sure
people eat that wanting to lose weight
or maybe change up their diet in a
certain way and yeah I think that's a
healthy thing being a salad it's not
it's not yeah anyway we could go on for
days well I do you have any others you
want to mention those it doesn't open
the Starbucks frappuccinos and stuff I
mean we're talking about basically ice
cream in coffee form and I've talked
about that a lot of those are you know
it's like eating an entire meal and
people are like I'm gonna go grab coffee
like really you're this is what you call
coffee but I'm not going to do that
entire rant again Pat's waving me off
from doing that
the edge again